[Applaudissements]
Thierry Cosic pour le groupe socialiste
écologiste et républicain
merci merci monsieur le Président chers
collègues la question s'adresse au
ministre de l'Économie donc son absence
le gouvernement a annoncé une
recapitalisation du groupe EDF EDF
lapsus lapsus révélateur de prime abord
cette décision est louable mais cela
cela semble être un peu large qui cache
la forêt de fait l'état actionnaires et
ta nouvelle est à nouveau tombé dans
cette pire travers les deux virgule un
milliard que vous allez faire payer au
contribuable vont compenser d'une main
ce que votre mesure sur le plafonnement
tarifaire a pris de l'autre par cette
recapitalisation le président candidat
qui se veut le président du pouvoir
d'achat devient celui du pouvoir de
rachat
et sur achat il se fait au détriment de
l'intérêt général pour restaurer la
confiance des investisseurs privés
la confiance ça n'a pas de prix et il va
en falloir lorsque l'on connaît
l'ampleur des chantiers qui attend EDF
dans les 50 prochaines années
comme je le déflorais il y a un mois ce
tour de passe-passe ne masque que trop
que trop mal votre absence de vision à
long terme en faveur d'une politique
énergétique sérieuse en France la
politique du carnet de chèque ne peut
constituer l'horizon indépassable de vos
investissements en matière d'énergie
nous avons déjà perdu 5 ans et nous ne
pouvons plus attendre la crise
ukrainienne nous prouve que nous devons
être le moins dépendant possible
d'entité extérieure au-delà de la
question énergétique c'est une question
de souveraineté nationale qui s'impose à
nous et ce alors que nous évoluons dans
un monde de plus en plus conflictuel un
réel état stratège doit opérer il en va
de la protection du pouvoir d'achat de
nos concitoyens vont mesurer ne
contiennent que trop peu la flambée des
factures d'énergie que ville pays
madame la ministre pouvez-vous dire à la
représentation nationale quelle mesure
structurelle envisagez-vous de prendre
afin de garantir la pérennité et la
viabilité financière du Groupe EDF
condition sinequanone on maintient d'une
politique énergétique économiquement
soutenable pour tous nos concitoyens